es geht um den corona bonus den haben
berbalk und habe sich selbst ausgezahlt
und im übrigen auch der gesamte grün
vorstand da gab es im sommer schon
mächtig stress jetzt aber jetzt
ermittelt die staatsanwaltschaft ja und
die grünen selbst die sagen sie wollen
diese vorwürfe schnell und
vollumfänglich aufklären dass also sagen
die grünen dazu und jetzt hätte robert
habeck die erste chance dazu in diesem
moment auftritt in bayern von ihm vom
wirtschafts und klimaminister vom
vizekanzler
er ist heute zu gast bei markus söder in
münchen in bayern und wir sind dabei mit
unseren reportern die staatsanwaltschaft
ermittelt gegen den kompletten
grünen-vorstand was sagt robert habeck
dazu wir sehen bilder gleich von der
ankunft von robert habeck dort heute in
münchen unser reporter hat den
konfrontiert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
morgen noch keine reaktion vom
vizekanzler vom grünen chef von
wirtschafts- und klimaminister auf
unsere reporter frage von unserem bild
reporter wolfgang hansch dort
unterstützer
klimaaktivisten dort in münchen aber
robert habeck das war nicht die letzte
chance sich heute zu erklären es wird
eine weitere geben nach dem treffen mit
markus söder bisher noch keine antwort
auf deine frage wolfgang aber du wirst
die gleich noch einmal stellen nämlich
an
die gelegenheit wird sein um halbzehn
will robert habeck und markus söder vor
die presse treten gerade eben hat er
sich viel zeit für seine anhänger
genommen als angekommen ist da haben so
gut 100 menschen hier gewartet
vor der bayerischen staatskanzlei
grüne fahren dabei den ging es vor allem
darum zu erklären
windkraft muss mehr gefördert werden und
die bayerische 10 hz regel muss
abgeschafft werden das soll er bei
markus söder durchsetzen und robert
habeck hat sich da auch richtig viel
zeit genommen kam so um 20 nachts um
halb neun war der eigentliche termin
hier in der staatskanzlei er hat sich
mitten rein gestellt und die leute hat
mit ihnen diskutiert hat mit ihnen
gesprochen hat fotos machen lassen und
hat sich da auch bei diesen themen
bereitwillig zu hören lassen aber erst
zweimal gefragt worden was ist denn
jetzt mit den staatsanwaltschaftlichen
ermittlungen was sagen sie dazu dazu hat
er erstmal nichts gesagt wir erwarten
dann nachher bei der pressekonferenz
nach dem treffen mit markus söder etwas
mehr
wolfgang ranft für uns in münchen vielen
herzlichen dank für deine information
mit dem studio begrüßen wir jetzt bild
moderatorin autorin aus unserer
wirtschaftsredaktion nina schenk ist
hier in der schönen guten tag
ermittlungen jetzt von der
staatsanwaltschaft das ist ein echter
paukenschlag
ich finde es ist mal wieder amüsant also
die grünen sind ja die moralische partei
die sind ja vier moralischer als wir
alle hier sieht man wieder essen
stinknormalen in einer stinknormalen
partei die auch nicht moralisch
erhobenen sind über uns andere parteien
was ist so spannend finde es gibt viele
familienunternehmer die sich während der
korona pandemie gar keinen bonus
ausgezahlt haben also in guten jahren
zeigt man sich ein aus so häufig im
wirtschaftsunterricht gelernt in
schlechten jahren nicht dass die
wirtschaft hat verzichtet und die
politik hat sich ein schönes taschengeld
ausgezahlt im fall von annalena baerbock
und übertraf man muss dazu sagen sie
haben nach parteiinterner kritik den
bonus dann zurückgezahlt also viel ärger
und die 1000 euro gab es nicht mal ganz
wichtig die moralische bewertungen in
diesem fall die hast du gerade
vorgenommen jetzt geht es um juristische
bewertung in diesem fall also die
schlagzeile heute der staatsanwalt hier
in berlin der ermittelt gegen robert
habe gegen annalena baerbock gegen den
kompletten grünen-vorstand wie ernst
muss die grünen-spitze selbst diese
staatsanwaltschaftlichen ermittlungen
jetzt also ist ja der verdacht der
untreue liegt ja im raum und es kam er
zu diesen ermittlungen ist es ja noch
keine anklage sind vorermittlungen und
ich würde sagen sie sollten schon ernst
nehmen bei nach bild-informationen die
habe ich auch direkt mitgebracht war es
auch thema im immunitätsausschuss des
bundestages und dort wurden die
ermittlungsverfahren auch als plausibel
gewertet dementsprechend wenn man
mitglied im bundestag ist hat mir eine
immunität den könnte aber aufgehoben
werden für diese ermittlung ich glaube
dass sie den veruntreuung skandal schon
sehr sehr ernst nehmen sollten und zwar
beide genauso wie die anderen im
bundesvorstand zum beispiel erkennen wir
haben über das moralische zeichen
gesprochen dass das ihr jetzt auch
irgendwie auslöst was denkst du ja was
ist die richtige art und weise jetzt
darauf zu reagieren was müssen habe ich
und berbalk jetzt tun also heute morgen
hat herberger schon wieder eine chance
vertan also ich würde mich an seiner
stelle äußern dazu ich finde erhält
heute schon ein statement abgeben können
rückblickend hat karina berger den bonus
ja auch schon 1 fehler damals gesehen er
wurde ja auch zurückgezahlt moralisch
muss man ganz klar sagen wenn man es
jetzt im nationalisieren würde wenn man
auf die krankenschwester und blickt
viele haben kein grüner bonus bekommen
die frauen im supermarkt die männer im
supermarkt und die beiden haben sich
ausgezahlt und jetzt auch noch gibt es
ja den veruntreuung skandal der iss sein
könnte übrigens kam es jetzt zu den
ermittlungen bei privatpersonen hans
angezeigt eine vielzahl von privatperson
hat es gemälde und daran sieht man auch
wieder grün regieren eigentlich am
bürger vorbei was sie in ihren
bundesvorstand entscheiden das ist doch
einmal gemeinsam darauf zeigen auch
drauf schauen auf die bilder von heute
früh aus münchen denn du sagst ja gerade
chance vertan wir haben ja gerade gehört
unseren reporter wolfgang ranft der eben
auf den spuren von robert habeck war er
gerade gesagt der hat sich viel zeit
genommen dort für diskussionen hier
sehen und hören die szene noch einmal
und dann fragt der robert habeck danach
und das passiert
nämlich nichts er nuschelt in die maske
so ein bisschen rein dass er jetzt ja zu
markus söder gerade läuft also das sagst
du chance vertan er muss heute stellung
nehmen sagst du aber auch dann später in
der pressekonferenz typisch kai robert
habeck zeigt sich gerne eins der
posterboy in der menge mit seinen fans
machten fotos er wird gerne angebetete
zeigt sich gerne auch natürlich heute
morgen aber wenn es dann zu den bitteren
themen kommt dann kennen robert habeck
auch er wie heute morgen und ich finde
er sollte sich definitiv dazu äußern zum
job unseres wirtschaftsministers gehört
nämlich nicht nur schöne fotos mit den
fans zu machen und über windräder zu
reden sondern natürlich auch in zeiten
wie diesen darüber zu sprechen und ich
muss man auch mal sagen das liegt ja
noch keine anklage vor trotzdem sollte
jetzt was sagen es geht ums image auch
und auch annalena baerbock heute jahren
relativ anstrengenden tag amtskollegen
sind zu besuch aus den usa aus
frankreich aus großbritannien es geht um
die ukraine auch sie sollte sich seiner
ansicht nach irgendwie äußern wie großen
deine erwartungen dass wir doch heute
von harbeck und von berbalk auch
wirklich was hören und dass wir das
richtige ich muss gestehen frau berbalk
für nichts passt ein bisschen schade ich
bin mir eigentlich immer als kritikerin
von ihm bekannt ich finde als
außenministerium ministerin macht sie
aktuell gar keinen so schlechten job
deswegen wird sie das glaube ich extrem
ärgern dass sie jetzt dieser skandal auf
klopp das muss man ganz klar sagen und
es ist ja auch beim parteitag und ich
denke dass die parteibasis sich auch
einige fragen dazu stellt und auch den
beiden stellen wird es wird einen
anschließend von den wein einfach auch
wieder schmutz hinterlassen weil in der
öffentlichkeit ist jetzt wieder nicht
nur dass sie sich ein ausgezeichneter
sondern er soll nicht als rechtmäßig
gewesen sei ich finde wenn man den
moralapostel partei nummer eins ist dann
sollte man auch öfter mal darauf schauen
sie auch so zu verhalten es geht um ein
corona bonus es geht um 1500 euro denen
die grünen-spitze sich selbst genehmigt
hat während millionen deutsche keinen
corona bonus bekommen hat und jetzt
ermittelt in dieser frage die
staatsanwaltschaft hier in berlin der
vorwurf ist untreue gegen die komplette
grünen-spitze dazu unsere bild
reporterin nina schenk vielen dank wir
hören uns später noch einmal denn das
ist der tag an dem der vizekanzler an
dem der grünen-chef und der wirtschaft
so klimaminister robert habeck dazu
stellung nehmen muss in münchen unsere
reporter sind vor ort und sie erfahren
dass hier in dieser sendung wenn er
genau dies tun wird die eine erste
chance in der konfrontation mit unserem
bild reporter hatte er heute früh sausen
lassen jetzt wird wegen untreue
ermittelt ja und in diesen momenten in
diesen minuten hat robert habeck die
möglichkeit sich zu erklären bei einem
termin in münchen in der staatskanzlei
dort erst heute als klima als
wirtschaftsminister zu gast bei markus
söder beim bayerischen ministerpräsident
aktuell treten die beiden gemeinsam auf
sie hören oder sehen hier oben rechts
schon das bild von dieser
pressekonferenz da geht es vor allen
dingen eben um klima um
wirtschaftspolitik sobald robert habeck
darstellung bezieht zu den vorwürfen zum
untreue vorwurf zu den
staatsanwaltschaftlichen ermittlungen
hier aus berlin heraus dann sehen sie
dass hierbei bild live ja eine chance
hatte heute morgen schon nicht genutzt
und sah reporter wolfgang ranft hat
versucht ihn vor diesen treffen
anzusprechen vor der staatskanzlei in
münchen
aber da ging robert habeck nur sehr sehr
schnell an den mikrofonen vorbei wäre
schon noch einmal in diese szenen herr
eines hatten sich viele vor der
staatskanzlei versammelten wie es zu den
straßen wird
[Musik]
also das war chance nummer eins heute
ich gehe jetzt erstmal zu herrn söder so
was in etwa hat er rein genuschelt in
die maske in diesem moment aber wie
gesagt das war nicht die letzte
möglichkeit unsere reporter werden
gleich danach fragen zu diesen
staatsanwaltschaftliche ermittlungen
über die wir hier im studio sprechen
wollen mit unserem bild politik chef jan
schäfer und weiterhin auch mit nina
schenk unserer politik und wirtschafts
autorin reporterin euch beiden hallo bei
uns im studio noch einmal das
einzuordnen ihr an
staatsanwaltschaftliche ermittlungen wie
ernst müssen die grünen das nehmen also
das müssen die grünen sehr ernst nehmen
und vor allem kommt dass diese ganze
ermittlung jetzt für robert habeck und
annalena baerbock natürlich zu einem
völlig falschen zeitpunkt also beide
stehen ohnehin unter druck wir haben es
gerade gesehen robert habeck muss seinen
masterplan für mehr klimaschutz durch
bringen ist heute bei markus söder der
ist ihm alles andere als leicht machen
wird und dann haben wir annalena
baerbock jetzt letzten tage gesehen auch
sehr schwieriger mission in der ukraine
und in russland so und da platzt jetzt
diese politische bombe rein dass die
staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt und damit
holt die beiden etwas ein aus dem
vergangenen jahr von dem sie eigentlich
dachten dass es hinter sich gelassen
hätten das eine ist ja der juristische
aspekte aber nena es geht ja auch um die
große frage der moral und moralisch
alten die grüne sonst ja immer sehr hoch
ja also zeigt einfach wirklich mal
wieder erneut dass du grund einfach eine
stinknormale partei sind mit ganz
normalen leuten sind und wir sind gar
nicht so moralisch erhoben sind wie sie
immer suggerieren und das ist hier
natürlich auch das sehr spannende ich
fand heute auch spannend als der
reporter habe konfrontiert hat also
vorher das bad in der menge als der
posterboy der grünen wer sich gerne
sehen und dann dazu wollte aber nicht
sagen ich bin gespannt was ich heute
noch einmal grünen haben ja genau das
versprochen die haben gestern eine ganz
kurze knappe pressemitteilung
herausgegeben und haben eben gesagt sie
werden dabei helfen das schnell und voll
umfänglich aufzuklären an dem schnell ja
dazu gäbe es heute eben die erste
gelegenheit dort in münchen deswegen
schauen wir auf diesen termin aktuell
live um das noch einmal einzuordnen sie
sehen um rechts im moment noch das bild
von markus söder den bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten und csu chef der hat
heute aber eben robert habeck zu gast
der steht neben ihm und der wird dort
auch gleich sprechen zunächst über klima
und wirtschaftspolitik und dann wird es
eben natürlich fragen geben zu dem
großen thema heute
staatsanwaltschaftlichen ermittlungen
bei den grünen gegen die den kompletten
grünen vorstand jan das müssen wir hier
im studio noch mal sagen den kompletten
grünen-vorstand weil die sich bonus
genehmigt haben den ganz viele deutsche
millionen deutsche selbst in der pflege
selbst in den krankenhäusern viele viele
nicht bekommen haben richtig es geht um
einen bonus der ausgezahlt wurde am ende
des jahres 20 20 und den hat sich der
bundesvorstand der aus sechs personen
besteht bei den grünen selbst genehmigt
wurde wofür war dieser bonus eigentlich
gedacht der war und es hat annalena
baerbock auch einmal gesagt im jahr 2020
der war gedacht für alle diejenigen der
pandemie besonders viel geleistet haben
also natürlich für pflegekräfte für
ärzte für aber auch kassiererinnen und
kassierer so und der punkt war dass
dieser bonus bis zu 1500 euro steuerfrei
ausgezahlt werden kann hat sich der
grünen vorstand gesagt super wenn das so
ist dann machen wir das auch einfach mal
ein problem gibt es auch noch also es
gibt 12 problem wir haben einmal dieses
selbst genehmigen das hat auch eine
interne prüfkommission bei den grünen im
herbst letzten jahres im erklärt das war
nicht in ordnung das nicht also ein
vorstand selbst etwas gönnt und nicht
beispielsweise ein parteitag oder ein
parteirat wie das bei den grünen auch
heißt und dann gibt es einen zweiten
punkt gerade bei annalena baerbock
annalena baerbock hat von den grünen
kein gehalt bezogen weil sie im
bundestag saß bedeutet sie war quasi
ehrenamtlich tätig aber jetzt kann man
wenn man ein ehrenamt ausübt nicht einen
corona bonus bekommen schon gar nicht
einen steuerfreien corona bonus das hat
ja unser kollege ralf schuler im mai
letzten jahres auch aufgedeckt und das
bundesfinanzministerium hat ganz klar
gesagt nein das geht nicht wenn ich ein
ehrenamt ausüben kann ich keinen
steuerfreien bonus kassiert soll diese
ganze affäre
dieses ganze debakel da gab es ja auch
noch die zu spät gemeldeten
weihnachtsgelder von annalena baerbock
das holt die grünen jetzt ein das ist
ganz ganz bitter gerade zum auftakt in
ein neues jahr das ja eigentlich aus
deren sicht ein grünes jahr werden
sollen das ist ein bisschen erklärte
dass alles zustande kam und er ich
glaube bei vielen bürgerinnen und
bürgern bleibt einfach hängen moment
weil wir gehen durch diese pandemie
durch wir kämpfen um unsere existenz wir
sitzen im homeschooling und wissen nicht
mehr ein und aus und irgendwo gibt es da
politikerin politiker die sagen einfach
her mit dem geldüberweisung check
gemacht was ist das für ein signal was
glaubst du was löst das bei vielen
menschen aus es zeigt der erneute
klientel politik der grünen eine grüne
politik ist ja auch nicht für den otto
normalverbraucher sei es die
solaranlagen auf dem dach oder andere
beispiel ich können wir uns lange
darüber referieren und auch dieser
selbst ausgezahlt und genehmigt die
krone bonus zeigt ja auch einfach wieder
da was es für die nt politik fern ab vom
bürger ist zum beispiel normale
angestellte wie ich da wird der bonus
aber ist noch frei gegeben vom chef hier
in dem fall weil wir ein schäfer aber da
kann man sich das einfach alles mal
selbst genehmigen das ist ein
das war ein kurzes ja
[Gelächter]
hören einmal ein bart haben
und die staatsanwaltschaft muss um den
sachverhalt aufzuklären
diese vermittlung einleiten wir
kooperieren vollumfänglich und das ist
der normale dienstweg und märz ab 20
nicht zu sagen das wird sich jetzt alles
sehr schnell aufklären zurück zur
energie der bund hat uns gebeten von
unserer seite einmal darzustellen auf
der einen seite sie war kurz und knapp
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass das nicht
das letzte mal war dass das bei dieser
pressekonferenz auch thema gewesen ist
da wird sicherlich auch weitere fragen
noch dazu geben aber robert habeck geben
haben dass hier gerade im studio gehört
ganz kurz und knapp gibt im grunde die
pressemitteilung von gestern einfach
noch mal wieder vollumfänglich wird man
kooperieren das aufklären gemeinsam mit
der staatsanwaltschaft das ist der ganz
ein ganz normaler dienst vorgang sagt
robert habeck also der vizekanzler und
wirtschafts und klimaschutzminister so
wie wir gerade gesehen haben ist
erkennbar angefressen ob dieser
politischen dummheit die ihm und seinen
parteifreunden da passiert es wirklich
erkennbar also natürlich ist es klug in
so einer situation nicht mehr zu sagen
wenn eine staatsanwaltschaft
vorermittlungen wie es ja auch gerade
gesagt hat leider hat aber dennoch die
ganze gestik das zeigt robert habeck
auch hier wenn wir die bilder nochmal
sehen von unserem kollegen wolfgang
ranft der ihn vor dem treffen und markus
söder noch mal befragt hat erkennbar
angefressen erkennbar sauer und das wird
zum einen mit markus söder zu tun haben
wären sicherlich heute ein rotes stopp
schild in sachen windkraft auch gezeigt
hat aber natürlich mit den ermittlungen
jetzt laufen das haut bei den grünen
voll ins kontor was wäre der eine satz
den er jetzt sagen müsste eurer meinung
nach nina jan einsatz robert habeck wie
müsste er sich heute erklären er müssen
sich entschuldigen es tut mir leid es
war falsch sein entschuldigung skonto
das ist oder dem schönen begriff vom
halben jahr gefahr für einen erwerber
ist bei herweck er noch nicht voll ich
finde er kann sich jetzt mal
entschuldigen wie siehst du das denn
würde auch sagen da müsste man sagen es
war eine große große dummheit
eins muss man noch mal sagen die grünen
haben ja im herbst letzten jahres diesen
bonus auch zurückgezahlt aber auch da
gab es eine debatte darum wir erinnern
uns annalena baerbock hat im frühjahr 20
21 darauf bestanden den corona bonus zu
recht bekommen zu haben lasse war ganz
nah sie hat doch gesagt sie zahlt ihr
nicht zurück dann gab es ein internes
prüfverfahren bei den grünen und dann
hieß es jetzt müssen die
vorstandsmitglieder diesen bonus doch
zurückzahlen auch zum teil noch teile
vom weihnachtsgeld so also da würde es
sicherlich sowie nina schenk es auch
gerade gesagt hat völlig zu recht
eigentlich lauten müssen liebe
bürgerinnen und bürger das war mist von
uns und jetzt gibt es vorher mitunter
staatsanwaltschaft und wir gucken was da
rauskommt ja wir gucken auch ob dieser
satz dieser entscheidende satz eine
entschuldigung noch fallen wird das
werden wir heute noch im lauf des tages
ganz besonders unter die lupe nehmen
euch beiden vielen herzlichen vor allem
besucher im studio danke